you posted a picture of yourself I'm
going to ask you about which is you
writing on a girl with a sharpie and
someone said that this is something that
you do occasionally yeah I do okay what
is this all about
I don't I don't think we have the pit
yeah yeah you're just and and and
someone said first of all you have for
permission I hope yeah those are Jason
Bateman's children and and I say we're
over at the pool and they wanted to get
a little temporary tattoos so we busted
out the sharpies and we did some tattoos
on his children so you like having
permanent tattoos obviously yes you have
to encourage them but on children you
feel like oh I'll give you a temporary
tattoo with a sharpie they wanted them
you know they're not getting anything
you know they're just getting ladybugs
and unicorns and stuff like that so so
yeah I just encouraged you just do what
Jason hates it because Jason Jason can
you just grab the non temporary marker
and maybe you know not do that right
yeah screw him
yeah what's your what's your best tattoo
that you give of all the tattoos you do
for a little bit it's pretty good
unicorn I've gotten good at that I've
done that one a couple times on maple
there and and ladybugs yeah those are
pretty good I have no tattoos would you
give me a tattoo right now before we go
to come yeah we're just cool with it
here no how about Rick right here
say I got alright here we go ready
that's my real flesh colour ladies and
gentlemen yeah you ever see a fish that
washed up on the beach and it's dying
okay thank you that's a little happened
X now that's I had my appendix out I'll
just few days ago let's have a hand for
the guy who has a pen tonight it was the
70s it was during the Jimmy Carter
Administration don't worry about it I
didn't even have to have it taken out it
was a protest it really didn't like his
foreign policy all right that is good
I'm big that is really good this is hot
this is gonna spice up my sex life when
my wife tonight when I drop my silk robe
and she sees Justin Theroux unicorn that
is really
[Applause]
good you know what I have my experience
with stuff with sharpies is it really
will not go away don't go for long yeah
yeah and I shower like once every three
weeks
so that's sticking around yeah
complicating that actually Jason
Bateman's told me that his children
refuse to shower because I didn't want
it to go away
right so he is he just hates you for a
lottery yes well he's a really bad guy
okay
just spread that around
you